this is tomorrow saying reading for
reviewer alessandro barbosa the original
release of blizzard's diablo sequel in
2000 was an inflection point for the
nascent arpg genre defining the
direction all games after it would take
but it's also a game that has been
drastically improved on in the decades
since its release which makes this 2021
remaster a confusing re-release that is
challenging to recommend over modern
contemporaries outside of reasons of
nostalgia or short-lived curiosity
[Music]
diablo 2 is a dungeon crawler albeit
stripped down to the genre's fundamental
basics you progress through the campaign
over a series of acts each contained
within their own map these maps have
distinct areas and enemy ridden dungeons
you'll need to explore eliminating
scores of enemies that drop all sorts of
color-coded loot that help you get more
powerful as you go the more you progress
the stronger you become allowing you to
deal the damage required to take down
incredibly dangerous bosses that provide
a challenging climax to each act where
diablo 2 differs strongly to its most
recent entry diablo 3 is in its role
playing here you're given three separate
skill trees to invest points into each
of which will go a long way in defining
what type of style your chosen class
will take you additionally need to
manage staple role playing attributes
like strength dexterity vitality and
more although these don't function as
you might expect points in each mostly
determine what gear you can equip and
not necessarily how much damage physical
ranged or magic you deal this can be
initially counted intuitive to how you
imagine each point invested will play
out with established diablo 2 players
already knowing that the majority of
these points need to go into vitality
and little else if you can already equip
the items you need this is an early
indicator as to what type of remastered
diablo 2 resurrected is at its heart
it's a pure recreation of the original
release idiosyncrasies and all with
every bit of content that launched in
the early 2000s its acts are incredibly
me with numerous quests both mandatory
and optional to undertake many of which
require you to scour the expansive
procedurally generated hubs that make up
each act having these layouts change
whenever you log back into the game
gives each one a small degree of
replayability but only if you're looking
to shake things up as you grind towards
your next level in order to make more
meaningful progress diablo 2's balancing
hasn't been changed at all which makes
this a necessary routine especially as
you progress into the harder
difficulties the gaps in this challenge
become more apparent acts where you're
tearing through regular enemies at a
comfortable pace will come to a
screeching halt when you encounter some
bosses who can wipe you out with just a
handful of attacks there's no warning
beforehand that you're unprepared for
the battle ahead which only serves to
make the penalty of death sting even
more you still drop gold and all your
gear when you die and having to daringly
make your way back to your body to
retrieve them remains as frustrating as
it was originally there is in fact very
little that has changed mechanically in
diablo to resurrected in a bid to retain
as much of the classic feel as possible
there's so much about diablo 2's design
that is hidden from you whether it's the
lack of damage numbers letting you gauge
the effectiveness of a gear change or
the puzzling reason behind your numerous
missed attacks the stamina bar also
hasn't been tweaked meaning a lot of the
early game will require you to stop
running and stereo as it slowly fills up
this is thankfully negated after the
first two acts as you start building up
more vitality points but never truly
goes away unless you dedicate time to
popping stamina potions frequently
diablo 2's character builds with their
respective strengths and weaknesses also
have not changed which means the game
remains as punishing as ever should you
not commit wholeheartedly to a specific
type of build the freedom of choice when
it comes to which skills to level up is
stripped away when you realize how rigid
the overall difficulty forces you to be
punishing wayward choices hours later
with a few options to rectify them you
do get one free skill respect per
character per difficulty and can gain
others through a lot of grinding but
it's an unwelcoming system for newcomers
to the game and especially fans looking
to enjoy an earlier entry after starting
with diablo 3. on pc you still don't
have a dedicated hotbar for spells and
abilities and instead have the slots for
left and right click actions you can
assign keys to specific abilities to
rotate them into your right click slot
but it's nowhere near as elegant as a
traditional hotbar that more modern
arpgs use to organize your abilities you
do get a dedicated hotbar when playing
with a controller letting you quickly
cast abilities with up to 12 dedicated
buttons using a controller then would
surprisingly be the preferred way to
play had it not been for diablo 2's
reliance on accuracy when casting
abilities which controllers just aren't
up to the task for in most cases a
controller is also a really poor way to
navigate the inventory which you will be
doing a lot of the time the control
scheme sits in a weird middle ground
with neither one offering satisfying
interpretations that is up to modern
standards and making actual play feel
clunky in one regard or another it's
understandable why mechanics like these
haven't been changed beyond the need to
adhere to the original design and it's
easy to empathize with the notion that a
classic like this shouldn't need to be
altered but it doesn't make the process
of playing it any easier small creature
comforts like stackable potions or more
inventory space over the poultry amount
you cannot upgrade would do wonders for
removing a lot of the tedious back and
forth travel you're forced to do between
your objective and your inventory stash
for example but that's not how diablo 2
played and that's why diablo 2
resurrected doesn't play that way either
which will either delight or weigh on
you depending on your established love
for its design choices what has changed
and drastically so is how diablo 2
resurrected looks it's a striking
transformation with all the details and
flourishes that modern hardware affords
lighting spells fill the screen with
their destructive arcing fury while
distinct details on the variety of nasty
creatures you'll face come alive in a
way that the pixelated original just
couldn't possibly manage the extent of
the work done to the game can be
appreciated by toggling back to the
original presentation which you can do
with a press over button at any time
it's eye-opening to see how the game's
tone and mood have hardly shifted and
just how powerful the dreary and
hopeless feel of it all was beautifully
communicated even with the visual
limitations of the mid-2000s diablo 2
resurrected pulls off the delicate trick
of looking like what your memories might
think diablo 2 look like at launch and
consistently being a treat for the eyes
some accessibility changes have also
been made such as aids for color
blindness and increase in the legibility
of the game's text graciously gold
pickups are now automatic which removes
some of the strain associated with
clicking all the little piles that
appear once you've killed a large group
of enemies smaller changes like the
ability to have text appear when an
attack misses or changing some key
bindings from presses to holes shows a
willingness to allow modern
sensibilities to creep in and improve on
the experience of playing diablo 2. and
since they're all optional they go a
long way to welcoming new players while
staying out of the way of returning ones
it's what makes the overall package such
a confusing one to recommend on the one
hand diablo 2 resurrected ticks all of
the boxes that a modern remake should it
remains faithful to the original and
doesn't mess with what came before given
players familiar with diablo 2 and its
idiosyncrasies a new strikingly gorgeous
way to enjoy the adventure all over
again it's also a reminder in some ways
of what was missing from diablo 3 with
its darker look and well-defined tone
sure to appease those who found
blizzard's eventual sequel too bright
and full of color but on the other hand
it remains an unwelcoming experience for
many players whose only reference to
this series is its latest entry those
who come from a background of being able
to freely experiment with character
builds whilst also reaping the rewards
of a power fantasy associated with
bombarding enemies with abilities at
ease will struggle to appreciate the
slower pace of diablo 2's combat while
also feeling shackled by its rigid
builds that don't forgive careless skill
point spending resurrected feels
squarely aimed at those who have already
poured hundreds of hours into this
genre-defining title all those willing
to do that additional homework of
reading up on its quirks ahead of time
to avoid falling into the trap of
building a non-viable character that's
not to say that the adventure is without
merit and it's certainly great to have a
way to play one of blizzard's classics
with a coat of paint that does its
visual aesthetic justice so many years
later but outside of players already
well versed with the game's age design
choices and imbalance there's not a lot
here outside of a history lesson for new
players to enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you